today's questions from Jay in Arkansas
I'm 43 with a household income of one
hundred and forty thousand and eighty
three thousand dollars in student loan
debt other than that our only debt is
the mortgage do we have enough time to
pay off the debt build wealth and give
generously sure pay off that debt in two
years that would be forty one thousand
forty one thousand five hundred dollars
a year and you would be debt-free in two
years out of one hundred and forty you'd
have to get by on one hundred grand give
me a break of course you can do that
definitely guys that's a simple thing
you can do by the way one of the things
that causes you to have hope is the
numbers sometimes you get hope from the
motivational talk the coach at halftime
right and then sometimes I'm that guy
sometimes you get hope from me kicking
your butt and getting you moving
sometimes you get hope from other things
but really if you'll just sit down and
crunch the numbers you start to go oh
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel that's not an oncoming train and
I it's some simple big math numbers it's
not even as rocket science here I'm not
really doing some detailed analysis you
look at the shovel in the hole how big a
hold of you and how much debt have you
got counting your house and or not
counting your house either one usually
not counting your house and then how big
a shovel do you have what's your income
in that case we've got a good-sized
shovel one hundred and forty thousand
dollars a year that's a nice income in
case you didn't know the average
household income in America right now
it's fifty nine thousand so that's
substantially above average but he's got
an above-average student loan debt to
the average student loan that's 37 and
he's sitting at 83 but look at 140
versus 83 and you start asking yourself
how fast can you pay that off well after
taxes you're not getting home with 140
and if you actually wanted to eat you're
not gonna pay off 83 in one year 140
minus taxes - 83
zero right and you're not gonna have any
money so we're not gonna do it in one
year
well what if we break it into two years
like I just said half of that's 40 grand
forty one thousand dollars each year for
two years out of a hundred and forty
that's very very doable so that guy
should be if he gets on a budget quits
going out to eat sells so much stuff
that the kids think they're next takes
an extra job lives on a budget that I
mentioned he needs to live on a budget
and his wife is helping him and they're
working together if he's married and if
you do that he should be debt-free in
about eighteen months but a maximum of
24 not counting his home making 140 you
should pay off 83 but it's just a ratio
of one forty to eighty three what if he
called what if he told me he had a debt
of 150 thousand well and be fifty
thousand a year for three years right
that's 150 divided by three you follow
me and just can you do that on making
140 yeah you can do it but that's gonna
be a long three years and they can do it
they can they can get there so you just
start to look at basically how long is
it gonna take him to knock that out and
he's gonna be 45 years old he's gonna
have a mortgage only can you become
wealthy doing that sure you got 20 years
left to invest you build your emergency
fund and you start investing fifteen
percent of your income if you invest
fifteen percent of your income for 20
years you'll be a millionaire most of
you certainly if you make one hundred
forty K oh and by the way during that 20
years you're probably gonna get a raise
or two so we're really not projecting
accurately because we don't know what
the raises are gonna be a linear
projection of 144 20 years at 15% that
would make him a millionaire investing
in good growth stock mutual funds inside
his 401 K in Roth IRAs just like we
talked about over and over and over and
over and over again
of course Dave Ramsey doesn't know
anything about investing he's good for
getting out of debt but Dave Ramsey
doesn't know anything about investing no
I've just turned more people into
millionaires than anybody else that's
all but I don't do anything that's you
know that's investing as a hobby and I
don't do anything weird and I don't do
any get-rich-quick and I'm not trying to
play a bunch of risk I simply want to
invest in something steady The Tortoise
wins the race every time I read the book
the hair loses and all these people run
around with flash and - he who hastens
to be rich will not go unpunished the
Bible says get-rich-quick will get your
face punched in I'm gonna start buying
and selling real estate I have no money
but I'm going to start buying and
selling real estate 100% down I mean a
hundred percent financed you're gonna go
bankrupt is what you just said it's just
a matter of when because the economy is
going to cyclone when the economy cycles
all the stupid that you're doing is
exposed
oran Buffett said when the tide goes out
you can tell who is skinny-dipping when
stupid gets stress tested you can tell
what's going on with it it's revealed as
stupid when you're making a ton of money
in the economy is on fire and white-hot
you start thinking well I think I can
you know I can do whatever here I can I
and you do you think you're stupid is
covered by just your prosperity but that
doesn't mean it's not stupid and but
when Snoopy gets stress tested it'll
show up don't have to get fancy guys get
out of debt use your income as your most
powerful wealth building tool and become
a millionaire and retire with dignity
I'm sorry I wish it was just some big
fancy thing but it's really not that's
yet that's the whole thing and if you
want something more sophisticated than
that then you're not following the data
points that millionaires follow you're
following something you read in
something stupid on motley fool or
something stupid which is aptly named or
something stupid on you know CNN Money
there's two things that don't go
together I mean think about it really so
I mean really why don't you just study
what rich people do and do what rich
people do why is this hard if you want
to be skinny talk to skinny people go
how'd you do that I stayed away from the
cookies and I ran five miles this
morning all right there's your plan why
is this hard it's hard because I like
cookies that's the problem
but that the problem with my money is
not that it's some big complicated thing
I don't understand the secrets of the
rich now you
want to control the person in your
mirror that's the problem the problem
with not my money is the person in my
mirror if I can get this guy in my
mirror to behave he can be skinny and
rich